[Music]
Chucky's show with how Rudnick hi
everybody I hate to use this show as a
soapbox but there's a minority group out
there that's been persecuted for far too
long and someone needs to champion their
cause of course I'm talking about
witches not sandwiches they've been at
the top of the charts for centuries I'm
talking Hansel and Gretel witches
speaking of which Hansel and Gretel
witch hunters is the number one film in
America what's up guys can't get enough
Gemma
Anderton anyway in the great tradition
of screen junkies journalism I went out
and found three real-life witches Anna
Robin and Shannon and we went and saw
the film afterwards we went back to
their lair for a spell sorry you guys
are actually witches yes yes do all of
you conduct spells yes anything from
getting a parking spot - can I hear a
little bit of your parking spot spell I
mean about a fellow listen mo yep I get
a cat sitting on the Yemen can you put a
spell on me to make my bigger I can once
upon a time
so we saw Hansel and Gretel yes boy did
we describe the movie in one word
unrealistic two words cheesy and graphic
seven words this movie was a piece of
whatever you do don't eat the candy what
did you think about the portrayal of
witches in the film well I think it was
very typical of Hollywood to portray us
in that sort of light if this was a
movie about black people and I was black
I would have a problem with it
so you're comparing the plight of
African Americans to the plight of
witches yes
wait a second hello we are portrayed as
monsters as horrible people
we're not even called humans in the
movie they weren't humans they had
monster faces and horns but that's not
what this is witches do you see monster
faces and horns
I thought repressed
I was sitting there totally repressed
repressed or oppressed both it's very
similar to the civil rights movement
because we have religious beliefs and we
should be covered under the First
Amendment just like everybody else
do you believe the way witches are
treated now is similar to what African
Americans have experienced in this
country no not even close
would you call yourself the Rosa Parks
of witches No would you call yourself
the Martin Luther King jr. of witches no
are you the Malcolm X of witches so
would that make you the Harriet Tubman
of witches I don't know that is I'm
gonna ask you what you think of
portrayals of witches in the media okay
practical magic let's get Blair Witch
Project good until I knew it was fake
charmed it portrays witches in a better
light Buffy never seen it you've seen
charmed but you've never seen Buffy True
Blood I don't want to blood watch
Breaking Bad no there's nothing to do
with witches this is a great show are
you friends with any vampires not that I
knew it any wolf men no have you ever
gone on a date with a Jason yes a hockey
mask Jason I don't know would you call
this film your Schindler's List no what
would you call your Schindler's List
Schindler's List would you call this
movie your 9/11 no what would you call
your 9/11 9/11 how many children have
you eaten
I don't eat children cool said it
clearly there's only one takeaway from
this witches are evil confession I
wasn't really paying attention to what
they were saying that was thinking about
Chipotle so guys what fairy tale
characters would you like to see kicking
some ass ugly duckling supermodel Slayer
Pinocchio whale killer or Jesus let us
know in the comments below and the best
answer gets a screen junkies t-shirt you
must have heard about JJ Abrams
directing the new Star Wars movie
spoiler alert the rancor hooks up with
the Cloverfield monster ah
[Music]
don't forget it's your show so let us
know what you want to see next I'm Hal
Rudnick by bike